hey youtubers is Charlie I'm back from
VidCon so this is gonna be my review of
korra episode 3 I just decided to
separate it out from those other two
episodes just in the name of sanity
things were going really crazy on Friday
I'll just say this if you ever have to
edit on a laptop do not forget your
mouse because it will not go well hello
to all the new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Korra videos be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I do episode of use you know bonus
videos q and A's there's no new episode
this weekend so episode 4 is gonna be on
July 11th but I will be doing a giveaway
for this video so if you didn't see my
episode 1 & 2 video I'm just giving away
a gift certificate for each episode of
Korra all you have to do to participate
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so this is just gonna be
like yesterday's video except I'm gonna
do my top 5 moments just because it's
for one episode so it's gonna revolve
around the earth Queen the Dai Li and
all the shady business in Ba Sing se
but careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet everybody ready
okay here we go number 5 Mok oh and
Bolin are too good for rotten fruit when
you look at all the different storylines
in the episode I feel like mokou and
Bolin reconnecting with their family was
every bit as important as Korra getting
the earth Queens help and on top of all
that my kid Bryan tied them getting
stuck in the lower ring to the Dai Li
plot you know in case you blinked you
may have missed them standing there
looking for more new airbenders at that
station and then later they were called
out during the dinner it took me a
second to figure it out but it's
actually pretty easy to see how Bolin
and Marco got cut off from their family
you know essentially their father saw
and he's where the connection is left to
make his fortune fell in love with the
firebender their mother and then they
were born so they weren't born in Ba
Sing se and since their parents died
when they were little kids they never
met their cousins
whenever Bolin was trying to convince
moko to drift back into the group at the
end of episode 2 it did seem like he had
communicated with his grandma previously
I may have missed it but I think that
was because of Bolin's nuktuk movers and
there they were just being screened in
Ba Sing se and his grandmother just saw
them and knew who they were however they
did end up connecting I'm really
interested to see if their cousins like
especially the rotten fruit vendor
cousin ends up helping them rescue the
airbenders the Dai Li plot and the earth
Queens secret army was kind of teased
during the dinner but right now there
isn't a real reason for their family to
fight with them and there
mother even got really weird whenever
they spoke ill of the Queen like she was
still a little brainwashed from the Dai
Li and last airbender in case you missed
it that grandmother was actually the
girl who had a crush on Zuko in the Ba
Sing se Last Airbender episodes it was a
nice little Easter egg number for corn
Asami learned they're fighting for the
wrong side while they were out tax
collecting during the battle you know
mr. Hakim ass
totally called it out the Queen is
wrongfully taxing her citizens at some
point this season that's gonna have to
be dealt with but I'm not expecting it
to happen anytime soon they introduced
way too many new plot threads to resolve
anything completely in the next episode
of course probably just gonna end up you
know poking the earth Queen until she's
straight up just unleashes the Dai Li on
them they did already take Kai but that
was incidental it didn't know he was
connected with the avatar whenever they
targeted him they just saw him as an
airbender so all that taxation stuff is
just a surface level problem she's
probably using that money to fund the
Airbender army so courts going to have
to solve that problem before she solves
the taxation problem number 3 the new
earth Queen is a total
big 180 from her father the earth King
in Last Airbender she seems like a
nazuna type person who just doesn't have
bending so I can totally imagine her
dominating her father while she was
growing up just getting whatever she
wanted she's totally nutters and I'm
actually wondering if she's gonna have
like an Azula goes crazy moment where
she just totally snaps in her defense
whenever she was explaining some of her
gripes to Korra Zuko and Aang
technically did take her land to build
Republic City but this is what happened
they used land through the Fire Nation
had taken from the earth Kingdom to
build colonies during the war of
invasion so it's only natural that Zuko
would want to use that land to make a
city dedicated to peace but it's like
stealing five dollars from your neighbor
then donating the five dollars to
charity you know yes you did something
good but you achieved it with stolen
merch so the earth Queens argument is
valid I can totally see her marching and
airbending army on Republic City trying
to take it back in the name of the earth
Kingdom imagine the spirits living there
going to war with them it would be like
Avatar wands episodes all over again a
conflict like that might even accelerate
vaatu's re-emergence it's unclear why
she's building that airbending army but
it's totally possible that the Dai Li
has been manipulating her just the way
they manipulated her father and it's
just not as obvious because she's so
headstrong
stubborn number-two korrasami kicking
ass I get such a good vibe from their
fight I wonder what the dynamic would
have been had Korah been the first
person to bump into Asami instead of
Mach oh and they never did all that teen
romance stuff in books 1 & 2 I love all
the implied ships encore just because
it's funny to think about the subtext
that way but I can totally do without
the you know the full-on over teen
romance I get the general sense that all
you guys are pretty pumped up about
korrasami this year you know with Naga
they're like a whole scooby-doo team all
by themselves in that situation I think
Korra would definitely be like a cross
between Shaggy and Fred and Asami would
be like a cross between Velma and Daphne
it's like they have all those good
qualities you know they're super smart
they have the brains and they have the
bravery but they're also super awkward
which i think is just gonna add up to a
really fun book 3 heads up - if any of
you are graphic artists and want to send
me some fan art of korrasami and naga as
the scooby-doo gang I'll be sure to add
it to my next bonus video and my number
1 moment the Dai Li is building a secret
airbending army so many questions here
we can only assume that since the earth
King disbanded the Dai Li during last
airbender they somehow resurfaced and
ingratiated themselves with the earth
Queen it's possible they rebuilt
themselves under the guise of you know
new leadership and have just been
running another long con evolving her or
taking advantage of her I know that
we're using the king as a puppet during
last airbender but it's possible that
the earth Queen is complicit in all this
shady business that all just depends on
what the motivation is for building that
army and I think it has something to do
with what Sahir said whenever he escaped
about closing your mind to the
possibility of a new reality the Queen
either wants to take back to the earth
Kingdom land or she wants to stop those
raiding parties from taking the gold
that she's been taking from the citizens
it's starting to turn you know more and
more into a Robin Hood situation
whenever they make Kai you know we got
the whole looks can be deceiving speech
so I wouldn't be surprised if all the
Raiders are really just freedom fighters
trying to help the people but now it's
your turn let me know below in the
comments what was your favorite moment I
know I didn't talk about the Bene twins
but I mistakenly put them in my other
video just cuz I forgot which episode
they were part of otherwise they would
have been like my second favorite thing
in this episode so the big news is next
week there's no new episode or next
Friday that is July 4th July 11th is
when episode 4 is gonna air hast
be doing a bonus video for July 4th and
I'll probably do a Q&A on Saturday too
so be sure to subscribe to get that
stuff nick is also probably gonna re air
those episodes in case you missed them
I'm also gonna be at Anime Expo in Los
Angeles this weekend so if you want to
find me and say hi just make sure to
follow me on Twitter Facebook or
Instagram I'm usually pretty good about
posting updates about where my face is
at any given moment
but right now click here to get my
episode 1 & 2 video and click here to
learn about the top 5 people that I'm
most excited for in book 3 thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]